sus rostros dieron la vuelta del mundo
cuando estalló la guerra en ucrania casi
tres meses después centenares de
personas siguen viviendo en el metro
subterráneo de jarquín
resisten porque tienen miedo y no tienen
a donde ir
clarisa tiene 61 años y un padre de 85
años que no se puede mover está leyendo
una novela cuando la encontramos
leer me ayuda a no pensar en lo que
ocurre afuera me distraigo de esta
manera aquí
es un sitio silencioso en casa es
imposible y
ahí empiezas a leer y empiezan las
explosiones
lina es otro rostro de esta vida bajo
tierra es una de las tantas personas de
los pueblos cerca de jarquín donde los
combates entre rusia y ucrania se
intensificaron en esta fase de la guerra
llegue de derecha y el 4 de abril a
principios de la guerra se podía estar
en mi casa entonces los bombardeos no
eran tan fuertes
a cada oficina pero luego se volvió
imposible dormir me escapé saliendo del
patio trasero de mi casa y me vine hasta
aquí
en heart que queda sólo el 20% de la
población es realmente impresionante ver
a estas personas durmiendo aquí en el
suelo resistiendo son los que no se han
podido o no se han querido ir de esta
ciudad victoria se estudia con su hija
catherine a ha decidido no dejar archivo
a pesar de que la niña sólo tiene 11
años no no me quiero ir pienso que
ganaremos me quiero quedar hasta el
final emprendiendo clarisa lina victoria
y la pequeña ekaterina son de los
símbolos de la guerra en ucrania una
humanidad que se ha tenido que esconder
para no perder la vida
[Música]